we're waiting what could be the most
explosive public and Pietschmann
testimony so far just an hour from now
we'll hear from EU ambassador that's
Gordon son he spoke directly and
frequently to the President on Ukraine
and he's already admitted he told
Ukrainian officials they would not get
US military aid unless they announced
investigations the president wanted
yesterday we heard from four witnesses
and all four raised concerns about the
White House is Ukraine policy
I found the July 25th phone call unusual
because in contrast to other
presidential calls I had observed it
involved discussion of what appeared to
be a domestic political matter I
couldn't believe what I was hearing
it was probably an element of shock that
maybe in certain regards my worst fear
of how our Ukrainian policy could play
out was playing out asking a foreign
government to investigate a domestic
political rival is inappropriate would
you not it's not what is on what we
recommended the president discuss the
allegations against Vice President Biden
are self-serving and not credible and
yet the president celebrated yesterday's
testimony from Tim Morrison and kurt
volker who told the committee they did
not have evidence of a quid pro quo Pam
Bondi is a special adviser to the
president this is her first interview
since she started on Monday Bondi was
previously Florida's Attorney General
she joins us from Washington miss Bonnie
good morning welcome thanks for being
here
good morning Thank You Anthony mr. as we
mentioned ambassador sunland is a key
witness this morning initially he
testified there was no link between aid
for the Ukraine and an investigation
into the Biden's but later said his
memory was refreshed and that there was
a quid pro quo how do you explain his
change in testimony well we're not gonna
get ahead of the testimony the testimony
is going to speak for itself today you
know every day during this testimony
what's everyone been saying explosive
testimony going to take down the
President of the United States that has
not happened and it's not going to
happen you know being a career
prosecutor and an attorney general and a
lawyer of all things the most important
thing to know is that this is our
Constitution this is the most C
Arius job that the House of
Representatives can do to try to impeach
a sitting president yet what have we
seen so far absolutely nothing
the witnesses yesterday did nothing to
hurt the president and we believe that
nothing will happen going forward
you know this all started in a bunker
with Adam Schiff and Democrats
Republicans weren't allowed in the door
that in fact they were kicked out of the
hearings hearsay was admissible and it
that's that's just what's continuing on
and on if you're going ticket for
jaywalking
you would have more rights for the
president's been afforded I'm sorry go
ahead Tony yeah I want to point out that
we've we've heard from career diplomats
non-partisans who've served multiple
presidents and some people who were
brought in to work for the Trump
administration specifically so I think
their concerns are significant and it
sounds like you're gonna stick by
whatever Gordon Silan has to say this
morning but the testimony that has
already been released regarding him
suggests that he does say there was a
quid pro quo so I think a key question
here now is he's bragged about having a
direct line to the president he's
bragged about being in touch with the
president the president says he barely
knew him so what's the truth well let's
let the testimony came out today and
let's see him let's see what the
Democrats ask him and what the
Republicans ask him and yes we know
Gordon Solomon well are they in frequent
contact have they been well we're gonna
hear what Gordon Solomon has to say
today he was he's in balance the
president was the president say the
president he was ambassador to the
Ukraine he is ambassador to the Ukraine
and the president knows him the
president does not know him very well
he's a short term ambassador of course
he knows him he's the ambassador but you
know let's go back to the two witnesses
that you talked about Ven Minh and
Williams what did they say
based on the transcript that by the way
other people have heard the transcript
read the transcript is very important
because it's not a transcript I want to
point out it's it's a call summary and
there's been some dispute about whether
everything was included I want an
shellac urine they both said it was
substantially accurate I want to get to
the facts I think they're very important
the American people want to hear that as
well and and somebody who's got all the
facts in his head right now is President
Trump himself he said he's going to
strongly consider testifying would you
support that
and one could it happen and how likely
do you think it is miss Bondi that the
president will actually justify good
morning Gail good morning I the
president i I know why he wants to
testify of course he wants to testify
because he did nothing wrong
but do I think it's likely he's going to
testify probably not because no one
would advise him to testify because this
is a sham court it really is what
they're telling him come in and prove
your innocence is that the system in
which we live now I believe things will
be equal and fair if it goes to the
Senate when it goes to the Senate but no
the president should not testify I know
exactly why he wants to though but no
human being should have to come in and
prove their innocence her miss body is
the concern that the president if he
were to testify he'd have to take an
oath to tell the truth is that
problematic absolutely not the president
has done nothing wrong and the president
would love to come in and take an oath
and tell the truth however when you have
a one-sided court where they're telling
him come and improve your innocence you
know Tony if you got a jaywalking ticket
walking across the street New York which
I know you don't do you would have more
rights then the President of the United
States has been afforded it's really
been outrageous it's a sham what they've
been trying to do yet the president has
continued running our country every day
and every day when this is going on
every day these hearings what are we
missing
USMC a how about it that is drug pricing
everything else there's money I want to
go down bachelor sunland because he says
to sue today again he has bragged that
he talked to the president whenever he
wanted is that accurate
well he clearly had conversations with
the President of the United States he's
ambassador to Ukraine but as far as aid
getting held up because aid was released
and we're very proud of that lethal aid
to Ukraine much more than the last
administration without any investigation
being open we're very very proud of that
and you know they're saying he held aid
back because of all these different
reasons that's not why
a drous released well well before the
deadline it was released on September
15th and a lot of things were going on
in our
then and you know have you seen the
letter that Ron Johnson wrote about the
aid being released back on August 31st
Ron Johnson says in a letter that the
president talked to him instead good
things are going to happen
aids going I think you're gonna be very
happy with what's going to happen
regarding the aid in London Thomas Bondi
before you go ahead Gayle how is the
president's health we know that he said
he was getting a jump start on his
physical I don't know any man that goes
early to a physical can you just tell us
how he's doing how is his health okay
first of all going early to a physical
was getting it out of the way because he
had a day on his calendar where he could
get to Walter Reed I was with the
president yesterday and I can tell you
directly from him his health is
excellent he did not suffer a stroke he
did not suffer a heart attack
not even close that is 100% fake news
and thank you for asking Gayle his help
is wonderful buddy thank you so much for
being with us thank you all you got to
discuss CBS News we'll bring you this
morning's public hearing and a special
report Norah O'Donnell will anchor from
Washington we expect testimony to begin
at 9:00 Eastern